I actually got names on delivery that I
ordered five days ago a little
concerning alright baby formula I could
be a little less worried the studio is
quiet everybody's gone no one is at
their desks it's very eerie we're all
hanging out and discord these days yeah
still fair number of cars at the street
those quieter than usual bunch of people
still at work down there little
concerning but plus the right balance
between taking time off your job and
watching out what people's health it's
hard to say
things are starting to spread but la is
still bustling though it is noticed a
quieter and the air is noticeably
clearer those probably due to the rain
and I'm just here all alone
hit outer street that's it here we are
stay tuned so far
imagine that this video is going to drop
a few days after I record this weird
watching City right now it's kind of
quiet but not really everybody's trying
to figure out where that right balance
is of
how much do you work do you go to work
to take time off I don't know people are
quite taking it as seriously as they
need to though it's been good to see the
mug people that are taking it seriously
I believe we made the right call and
sending people home and having people
work from home right now
hope that other employers and bosses
would make the same call but looking at
the street that's not really what I'm
seeing but it's interesting to see how
people's sense of civic duty is coming
together here some people are into it
other people are but I think it's a bit
of a wake-up call for people
good educational moment you know
anyways let me show you a little bit
about what I'm doing around here while I
deal with myself for tea
[Music]
hi Cory so this is my workstation so
where I'll be doing all my work for the
next two weeks hopefully just the next
two weeks and not more than that
so this pace used to be the old core or
digital offices and the old Freddy W
offices and on the ground you can
actually see the spots of everybody used
to sit because we didn't have any
protective stuff for our chairs so this
big spot here is where Jimmy used to sit
in his little L desk this fart here's
where Freddy used to sit in his desk
right there if you look like his old
videos then we had tables right here we
had chairs right there at those worn
down spots so like I was like the same
was there for a while I was there and
we're there Brandon was over here
somewhere probably below the carpet you
can see the frames of it right there
yeah all those worn spots on the floor
we used to however really chairs from
those years ago when he started the
channel interesting stuff hi
probably the best part about working
from home does they get to spending time
with my almost 7 month old daughter by
though my wife Ivy who is holding the
camera currently I mention cats you know
they say when it comes to babies that
the days are long that the years are
short so don't get a lot a whole lot of
time with them when they're this size
it's nice to be home to see your a
little bit and watch a girl so that's
nice
one bright side of everything I'm also
going to be playing a lot of video games
[Music]
so we just got some food to go I've
never seen Pasadena so much like a ghost
town oh boy yes so here we are at home
self quarantine trying to do work that's
the whole thing we've all been
communicating our discord live chats
pretty much on all day slacked using
that a lot I've got a new scale video in
the works that I'm gonna try producing
during this time at home because that's
mostly something I can do on my own so
might as well do it you know I'm sure a
lot of you guys have concerns about you
know this whole Cove it 19 business the
best thing you can do is stay home you
know you hear people talking about
flattening the curve which is just the
idea of trying to not overrun the health
care system you know hospitals only have
a certain number of beds total and most
of those are already for previous
patients let's talk to my wife Jenna she
is a charge nurse at a hospital she
pretty much runs the entire hospital
floor she works on let's hear what she
says about some of this stuff Jenna as a
health care professional what is your
opinion of this whole : 19 thing is it
all overblown are people panicking for
no reason in some ways but not others
it's like people panic the buying
unnecessary Indus ruining it for people
who really need stuff stings shutting
down not a good idea is it a good idea
that I'm within our 6-foot bubble right
now I like it what are some of the
percussions you're starting to take out
your hospital it's still
work-in-progress we're still figuring
out what needs to be done cause stuff
keeps tell me now it's a novel virus for
a reason and that we don't know much
about it
managers supervisors everyone's staying
super long hours just learning about
what's changing what they need to do
we're now having to be more picky about
yes masks not everyone can have one
because it's not appropriate and we have
to save them from we need them so what
exactly is a mask necessary if you were
sick so that you don't spread it to
other people so if you are beginning to
show symptoms but you're not sure it's
the corona virus what should you do stay
home so any home yeah if it becomes more
concerning you can call your doctor they
could advise you don't go to the
hospital you wouldn't normally go to the
hospital far across if they do test you
which they might not because there's a
limited amount of tests and they'll only
test people for exhibiting symptoms in
mostly high-risk there's not like a cure
for it it's only they only treat the
symptoms so if you have a cough stay
home get rest drink fluids
get better so at what point should
someone go to the hospital so like if
they're experiencing shortness of breath
at rest if you'd go to the hospital for
what you're experiencing go to the
hospital what if you get sick then in an
ideal world you stay home but it's tough
because it's when as a nurse you don't
want to pull off because you feel bad
putting all your other co-workers and
alerts because they're short but at the
same time if you go in sick and you get
other people sick and then all the
health care workers are sick who's going
to take care of the patients or those
nurses and that sport becomes even more
dangerous because it's like you're gonna
be a carrier for ten days without
knowing that you're sick meanwhile
you're interacting with patients there's
just nothing you can really do about
that nurses can't self quarantine just
for the sake of self quarantine you have
to still go to work to take care of the
people who are sick you're in a bit of a
tough position here me and how many
other people yeah well props to all the
nurses out there doing your part respect
young belief also grocery store workers
because I felt for you when I went to
the store for real though awful
it's good thing pets can't get Corona
what's that corridor through how you do
and it is day 2 of the quarantine work
from home for our corridor so as you can
see I have my battle workstations set up
for working from home and chatting with
the guys and doing edits possibly more
on that later but today I want to show
you a cooking recipe that is perfect for
cooking at home for you or your
quarantine buddy
that is super easy and doesn't take a
lot of ingredients theoretically you
could already have these ingredients
within your quarantine supply so let's
get into it
400 degrees all you really need is an
onion pack of chicken thighs or any no
chicken legs whatever works and a one
cup of rice and some chicken broth and
then your side of vegetable of choice
I'm gonna do asparagus today Tommy you
can do anything that goes good with
chicken and rice all right now that your
oil is heated place each piece of
chicken skin side down for about four
minutes
over for another four to five minutes
[Music]
sitting outside
once that's going and one cup of rice
[Music]
more salt
and you want to bring that to a boil
once that's boiling put your chicken
back on top skin side since that is
still boiling and then go ahead and move
on and that's it pretty much at about 20
minutes left I'm going to cook those
vegetables but other than that when the
timer is up you should have an all in
one pot dish perfect for lunch or dinner
for two
during this quarantine time so hope you
guys enjoyed stay safe out there make
sure you're washing your hands being
clean hopefully I can show you guys a
new cooking recipe sometime soon but for
now let's check in with one of the other
guys and see how their quarantine is
going this is a camera test can you hear
me JJ can they hear you hey guys
Earl McGregor here and I thought well
all the guys are out doing their thing
talking about their quarantine I thought
it would be a nice opportunity to go
over all the things that I've prepared
for an emergency just like this okay
first things first make sure you have
the right gear on your body because in
any emergency you gotta be ready for
anything so the first thing that you
need is a nice hat okay the next thing
that you're gonna need a defend
America's shirt because you never know
what you're gonna have to defend next a
watch I got a super watch here it tells
time next thing nice sturdy pair of
pants and finally a pair of boots
show them your boots come on okay he'll
get there the next thing you're gonna
want to do if you make sure that you
have all the right apparel on is check
in with your family make sure that
they're all safe back here we have
quarantine daughter and that's
quarantine wife hey little man how you
doing
okay once your family is that all
accounted for
the next thing you're gonna want to do
is check all of your gear accoutrements
and equipment to make sure that you're
ready first and foremost check your
fridge make sure that it's on and
plugged in and that it has electrical
power that's very important make sure
you've got some milk two boxes of cereal
make sure that you have plenty of books
because if the internet runs out you can
I want to keep your mind sharp and you
also might need to look up some
information now I heard that there's
information in books
so hopefully the internet won't go out
if it does you can always just reset the
modem there's one right there
okay make sure you've got your firearms
ready now this here is a BB gun I found
lying around my garage okay it takes a
couple of pumps make sure it's on safety
and make sure your fingers not on the
trigger unless you're ready to fire it's
gonna be very important that you have
one of these in case there's any rats or
birds that you don't really want on your
property okay
all right last but not least you're
gonna want to make sure that you have a
first aid kit these are also great
because they're portable you can put
them in a backpack you can put them in a
car and I just happen to find this one
line around the garage those are all the
things you're gonna need to properly
survive a quarantine if you guys are out
at home and you're watching a bunch of
these YouTube videos and you're thinking
hey you know it'd be great a playlist of
a bunch of Awesome corridor videos and
other videos from the corridor universe
that I could watch right now here on
YouTube guess what there's a link it's
probably up here right now a quarantine
playlist so if you're at home and you
want a bunch of awesome original funny
corridor videos go on and check that
playlist out it's definitely in the
description below yeah I'll be safe
y'all be saying we're all gonna get
through this all right I believe in you